WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO THE
CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS ENDED
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS THE NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHEERS ME
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDEWILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME. TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR LEAD WITNESSES TODAY WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES FOR EACH
WITNESS AND THERE IS NO
RESERVING. TIME FOR OTHER
WITNESSES. ALL OTHER WISHING TO
TESTIFY MOST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS THEIR NAME OF. AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURES. FOR
THOSE WITNESSES THERE WILL BE A
LIMIT OF TEN MINUTES FOR
SUPPORT IN TEN MINUTES FOR
OPPOSITION. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS NOW.
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE TO RISK FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY IN THAT MANNER.
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. FOUR REPEATED.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. AND YOU
NEED AN ACCESS CODE WHICH IS
EIGHT ONE EIGHT. TWO EIGHT ONE
SEVEN. AGAIN ACCESS CODE IS
EIGHT ONE EIGHT TWO EIGHT ONE
SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE TOTAL
COMFORT SYSTEM WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE FOR THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE. THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. PURPOSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
COULD BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER HE
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE ON MUTE IN. AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY. AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING AND HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEANING
SERVICE TO HAVE. OR HAVE. A
REPEAT OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER. AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
WAIT TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGY.
SO PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL
IMPATIENT. WITH ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
NINE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA WE
HAVE FOUR BILLS ON CONSENT
THOSE BILLS OR THE S. YOUR FIVE
FORTY. A. B. FOUR FOUR FOR AN
A. B. TWELVE SEVENTY THREE A
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATION ON
THE BILLS BUT SYSTEM IS A
CORPSMAN ASKING SALUTE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CENTER
PROTESTING HERE THIRTY HERE ARE
TROUBLED. SHOWBOAT HERE THE
RUSSELL HERE THE HERE LAYARD
HERE LAYERED NEWMAN HERE. YOU
KNOW WHENEVER HAVE GONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SIMILAR TO MOVE
ME TO THE CAN CAL IS ENERGY A%
MOTION TO SET UP. WE THINK THAT
WAS WHERE THE ONE THAT RACE THE
MOON- IF NOT IT WAS NEWMAN WITH
DIRECT SHOW. IT'S A IT'S WE'RE.
BOTH OF THEM WERE SOON BUT WAY
TO NORMALLY REFER TO BUT THEIR
LAST NAMES OF ELSA CONSOLE
PLEASE THE ROLL. I FOR BECAUSE-
AS THEY ARE FOR. AB SEVEN SIX.
AB FOUR FOUR FOUR A. C. FORTY
FIVE. SO PER. HI. IT IS THE I.
OF SENATOR SHOWBOAT. I CENTER
THE. OF THE I SENATOR LAYER I.
NOTIFY NEWMAN HI. THE BILL HAS
FIVE BOOKS OKAY CONCERN CO
OWNERS OF. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
WE WILL MOVE ON FILE NUMBER
TWO- A TWO EIGHTEEN. A AUTHOR
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON.
BUT BOOK YEAH POLICE OF FREE TO
MAKE YOUR PRESS THE YOU. THANK
YOU MISS CHAIRMAN. FROM HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY TWO
NINE WHICH SEEKS ENSURE
FAIRNESS AND DISTRICT SAYS
ELECT. OUR SYSTEMS ARE CIVIL
SERVICE TO PREDICATE ON A
WELCOME AND- WORK FOR. TODAY
THERE ARE A HUNDRED K. THROUGH
TWELVE AND COMMITTED COLLEGE
SCHOOL TO. IT'LL EMERITUS TO
AND PROMOTE. AND PLEASE AND ARE
DEFYING AS NOT CREDIT SCHOOL
DISTRICT EMPLOYEE. SUCH AS
EDUCATORS WORKERS TO NAME A-
EXISTING LAW AUTHORIZES THE
ADOPT ROOM OF SCHOOL MAYOR
SYSTEM BY MAJORITY FOR. OF
CLASSIFY EMPLOY. THIS BILL WILL
EQUITY THESE AND DURING SYSTEM
ELECTIONS AND ADDS IMPORTANT
OVERSIGHT TO THE ELECTION
PROCESS. HERE WITH ME REMOTELY
IS DELORES AROUND FLORES WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND JOHN BAIRD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL PERSONNEL
COMMISSIONERS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU MY UNDERSTANDING IS-
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS ON THIS
BILL TODAY IS DOORS GROW FLOOR
IS- IN ALSO AVAILABLE EVIDENTLY
IS JOHN BAIRD HERE- WE WILL
MOVE TO THE. INDIVIDUALS AT
THIS TIME ON AUG OR GRAND IS
SON BELIEVE SUPPORT WITH. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN THAT MY NAME
IS THE RIGHT TRANSPORTED BY
REPRESENTING SCHOOL ASSOCIATION
EARLIER THIS OF THE BABY NOT.
WILL PROVIDE BETTER THAN THE
MATTE BLACK. CENTER MANY BEFORE-
THAT COST THE TO CONVO WITHOUT
STARRING ACTION. NOT ONLY.
TRACK BUT WELL I LIVE IN A FORM
THANK YOU THANKS THAT. SECOND
AB TWO EIGHT NINE A CLASSIFIED
EMPORIUM COMMITTEE TABULATION
COMMITTEE HOW ABOUT THE REPORT
THE RESULTS TO THE GOVERNING
BOARD BUT IF THE NEXT AVAILABLE
FOR DISTRICTS TO HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE COMMITTEE
I'M NOT. GOING TO ONE SURE BOTH
SIDES ARE PROVIDED AFTER THE
AND WEBER DISTRICT ELECTION
COMMUNICATIONS. THAT ARE ABOUT
FINALLY. TWO EIGHT NINE FROM
CLASS EMPLOYEES THE BARTENDER
BOTH HELLO OF BLACK ABOUT A
VOICE FROM. POP THAT. AB TWO
EIGHT NINE ZERO THAT PEOPLE OF
TRANSPARENT WITHOUT HIM. AFTER
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
WILL MOVE MOVE TO WITH. IN THE
CAN ROOM OR ANYONE HERE. TO
SPEAK AND- OF A BILL TWO EIGHTY
NINETY THE COMMITTEE. A C. ONCE
FOR WE LOOK TO THE- OVER FOR
OVER- THERE APPEARS TO BE NO
ONE THERE TO TESTIFY. I WILL
MOVE NOW TO THE MODERATOR IN
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE IN.
ASSAM MODERATOR TO QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
EIGHTY NINE A PLEASE LET US
KNOW THE NUMBER SPEAKERS IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
EIGHT NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE IN Q. FOUR
NINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GLAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO CARE AND
MEMBERS OF THE SAND CASTLE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACT YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE. THANK YOU MOTOR
IS ANYONE ELSE IN THE SUPPORT
QUEUE. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT TO THANK YOU
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES OR ANYONE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WHICH SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTY NINE.
SEEN NONE LOOK TO THE OVERFLOW
ROOM. A SCENE NO WITNESSES IN
THE OVERFLOW ROOM BUT WILL
AGAIN GO BACK TO THE MODERATOR
IN ASK YOU TO QUEUE UP ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ABTWO EIGHTY NINE. AGAIN
PLEASE LET US KNOW THE NUMBER
OF SPEAKERS. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION- AB TWO
EIGHT NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
TEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. CORITIBA
MODERATOR- WITHOUT TO WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BEFORE.
WE MOVED TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON TO CLOSE. I SEE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SOME OF THE
BILL I'M SORRY. THERE'S. ALL
RIGHT I SEE THEM OUR GOAL IS
NOT TO DELAY SAY. ONLY HAVE ONE
WITNESSES TO WHO MADE THE
MOTION ON NOTICE- SO MOTION BY
SENATOR DRAWS SO- WE WILL ASK-
CONSULTANT TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR
COURTESY BY THE TO THE AYE A
SHORT BOOK. GLOBAL GUY WRESTLE.
RUSSELL I LAYERED. I NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT. NEWMAN AYE THAT HAS FIVE
BOOKS. THIRTY TWO THE- BILL THE
VOTE IS FIVE TWO ZERO VISIT AND
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU. NEXT UP WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA HERE TO
PRESENT ON ASSEMBLY BILL. THE
FIFTY SEVENTH. WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GOOD TO SEE YU THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER AND MEMBERS.
I TO PRESENT AB EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN WHICH WOULD REQUIRE H.
TWO A. VISA EMPLOYERS TO
PROVIDE ALL EASILY FARMWORKERS
WITH WRITTEN NOTICE OF KEY
STATE AND FEDERAL EMPLOYMENT
RIGHTS INCLUDING INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR RIGHTS. DURING
FEDERAL AND STATE EMERGENCIES
AND DISASTERS. LAST YEAR MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
FOREIGN FARMWORKERS WERE
IMPORTED BY ROUGHLY ONE HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA GROWERS AND FARM
LABOR CONTRACTORS UNDER THE H.
TWO A. FEDERAL VISA PROGRAM.
THIS NUMBER HAS BEEN INCREASING
ANNUALLY THESE TO ME
FARMWORKERS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
LARGELY RECRUITED IN MEXICO ARE
TIED TO A SINGLE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYER WHO PROVIDES THEM WITH
HOUSING MEALS AND
TRANSPORTATION TO WORK SITES.
MANY IS TO YOU IS TO WORKERS
I'VE NEVER BEEN TO CAL BEFORE.
ANOTHER SPEAK OR READ ENGLISH.
IF YOU'RE FIRED FOR ANY REASON
THEY'RE SUBJECT TO IMMEDIATE
DEPORTATION WHICH IS A POWERFUL
DISINCENTIVE TO REPORT ANY
ABUSE OF BURKE PLEASE
CONDITIONS THEY ARE SUBJECTED
TO. AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN SEVEN
SIMPLY REQUIRES H. TWO AM
PLAYERS TO PROVIDE EASILY
FARMWORKERS ON THEIR FIRST DAY
OF WORK. A SHORT COMPREHENSIVE
WRITTEN SUMMARY OF KEY LABOR
TRANSPORTATION RELATED. HOUSING
AND HEALTH AND SAFETY LAWS IN
SPANISH. AND FOR QUESTION IN
ENGLISH. THE BILL ALSO DIRECTS
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER DEVELOP
A TEMPLATE CONTAINING THE
SUMMARY AND A POSTER ON THE
WEBSITE FOR EACH TO EMPLOYERS
TO USED TO COMPLY WITH THE
NOTICE REQUIREMENT. H. B.
EIGHTY SEVEN CREATES A SEPARATE
LEGALLY COMPLIANT WORKPLACE FOR
AGE TWENTY FARMWORKERS.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL IS MARK SHOT THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
CYNTHIA RICE DIRECTOR OF
LITIGATION ADVOCACY AND
TRAINING FOR CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
WE WILL MOVE INTO THE LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESS MARC SCHECHTER.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS-
MARKS OUT THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL- THE BILL
ADDRESSES A SINGULAR PROBLEM
FACED BY AGE TO A FARMWORKERS
TO ENTER CALIFORNIA UNDER
FEDERALLY APPROVED JOB OFFERS.
THAT OFTEN INCLUDE TERMS THAT
UNDER STATE LAW ALL RIGHT THE
FALSE OR MISLEADING OR
INACCURATE WITH NO STATE OR
FEDERAL AGENCY CHARGED WITH
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE GAS
WORKERS WITH CORRECT
INFORMATION. IN FACT IN RECENT
AND ROUGHLY 50% OF THE NEARLY
THREE HUNDRED JOB OFFERS WE
REVIEWED IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND
TWENTY TWENTY EMPLOYERS FALSELY
STATED THAT RESIDING IN
EMPLOYER HOUSING CREATES NO
TENANCY. BEEN MISLEADINGLY
STATED THAT RIDING IN THE
EMPLOYERS BOX FROM HIS HOUSING
COMMITTEE NIELSEN'S VOLUNTARY
IMPLYING THAT IT IS NOT
COMPENSABLE BY MANY OTHER
EMPLOYERS FAILED TO DISCLOSE
THAT OVERTIME PAY IS REQUIRED
AND OTHERS INACCURATELY STATED
WHEN OVERTIME PAY APPLIES.
BASED AT. AB EIGHT EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN IST PRESS SIMPLY A FARMER
CORRECTIVE NO STATURE PROPOSED
TO GATHER AS CHAIRMAN SAID. I
OF COURSE MEAN FOR MAKING INTO
A SINGLE WRITTEN NOTICE-
PROVIDED TO WORKERS IN SPANISH
ON THEIR FIRST DAY OF RUSSIA
BUT NAY BRIEFLY ADDRESSED THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE FOR S.
B. ELEVEN OH TWO MINING. WHICH
IS BILL CLOSELY TRACKS FIRST
THE GOVERNOR STOPOVERS BUT HE
SUPPORTED THE POLICY OF S. B.
ELEVEN OH TWO BUT HE FELT THAT
IT GENERALLY DIDN'T GIVE THE
AGENCY SUFFICIENT AUTHORITY
RIGHT JUST LANGUAGE OF THE
NOTICE TO ADDRESS NEW OF APPEAL
LOG. PART OF ELEMENTS IN CASE
ROSS AS THE BILL IN OUR LETTER
TO THE COMMITTEE STATES- WE
ADDRESS ALL OF THOSE ISSUES
SECOND. ALTHOUGH THE VETO
MESSAGE DIRECTED THE LABOR
AGENCY FOR THE BALLOT BUT
NOTICE CONSISTENT WITH THIS
BILL I'M GONNA KILL THE
GOVERNOR LACKS THE LEGAL
AUTHORITY IN A VETO MESSAGE TO
MANDATE THAT THE NOTICE BE
DISTRIBUTED BY EACH EMPLOYER.
EVERY H. TWO A. FARMWORKER THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THAT NOTICE IF
IT IS EVER DEVELOPED. IT'S
ENTIRELY VOLUNTARY ONLY EIGHTY
FIVE SEVEN RIDE YES B. ELEVEN
OH TWO. REQUIRES A BIT FROM
PEOPLE INTO THE OF EVERY. AND
WE WERE. ASK THREE I. BOATS NAY.
THANK MR SACK- SINCERO ARE YOU
TO TESTIFY. AS LEADOFF LEAD
SOME WITNESS. I YES I AM GOOD
MR CARE MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS CYNTHIA RIGHT I'M A
DIRECTOR OF LITIGATION FOR
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE WE REPRESENT HAVE
RECOVERED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR H. TWO A. WORKERS. AB EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN DOES NOT CHANGE THE
CASE ON DEFINITION OF
COMPENSABLE TRAVEL TIME FOR H.
TWO A. WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
ALL TIME SPENT UNDER THE
CONTROL OF AN EMPLOYER MUST BE
COMPENSATED. IN COURT IN REALLY
AND MAKE CLEAR THAT EXTENDS TO
TRAVEL TIME. IN CASE OF LIKE
THOSE REFERENCED IN THE
COMMITTEE REPORT S. CHELSEA AND
ALKON CAR. REJECTED THE NOTION
THAT IS A QUESTION OF WHETHER
THAT TIME IS CHARACTERIZED AS
MANDATORY OR VOLUNTARY.
RECOGNIZED BUT IN AT LEAST
THREE CHOICE IS NO CHOICE AT
ALL. AND THAT COMPENSABLE WITTY
TURNS ON WHETHER THE EMPLOYER
CONTROLS WHEN WHERE AND HOW THE
EMPLOYEE GETS TO WORK. H. TWO
A. WORKERS ARE BROUGHT INTO
THIS COUNTRY BY THEIR EMPLOYERS
AND ARE ASSIGNED TO SPECIFIC
HOUSING SITE THEY HAVE NO CARS
NO PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION IS
AVAILABLE. AND THEIR ACCESS TO
OTHERS WITH LIMITED. EMPLOYERS
CONTROL THEIR AGE TO A CRUISE
BY TELLING THEM WHEN AND WHERE
TO REPORT NOT TO A FIELD OF
WORK LOCATION BUT FOR BUSTER
VAN. RIVERSIDE BAND TAKEN TO
THE WORK SITE SOMETIMES AN HOUR
AWAY. AFTER THE FIELD WORK ENDS
WORKERS WAIT AGAIN FOR THE
EMPLOYER TO SEND THE BUS TO
COME AND PICK THEM UP AND TAKE
THEM BACK. THEY ARE UNDER THE
CONTROL OF THE EMPLOYER DURING
THIS ENTITLED TIME ENTIRE TIME
AND ARE ENTITLED TO BE PAID FOR
THAT TIME. THEY'RE PAID AT THE
REGULAR RATE OF PAY WHICH FOR
H. TWO A. WORKERS ACCORDING TO
FEDERAL H TWO A. LAW. IS THE
ADVERSE EFFECT WAGE RATE. A
HIGHER RATE OF PAY SET
SPECIFICALLY TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS NOT A FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE TO REPLACE US
WORKERS. WITH H. TWO A. FOREIGN
WORKERS. THE OPPONENTS OF THE
BILL SEIZE UPON THE FOLLOWING
TERRY LANGUAGE OF MOORLAND BUT
IGNORE ITS ANALYSIS AND THE
TWENTY YEARS OF KESA APPLYING
IT TO A BALL SITUATIONS. THEY
DO SO TO PROTECT EMPLOYERS WHO
CURRENTLY IN THEIR CONTRACT
LANGUAGE AND ON PLACARDS AND
THEIR BUSES. PRESENT AN
ILLUSORY CHOICE BY STATING THAT
TRANSPORTATION IS VOLUNTARY
WHEN NO REAL ALTERNATIVES EXIST
FOR THESE WORKERS. CURRENTLY
AND UNDER PROPOSED SECTION
TWENTY EIGHT TEN POINT FIFTY
FIVE OF THE BILL H. TWO A.
WORKERS WHO HAVE TRUE
ALTERNATIVES TO GET TO WORK AND
ARE NOT REQUIRED TO TAKE THE
BUS. ARE NOT ENTITLED TO
COMPENSATION JUST AS THEY ARE
NOT UNDER CURRENT LAW. AB EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN MERELY ENSURES THAT
WORKERS ARE ADVISED OF THESE
AND OTHER WELL ESTABLISHED
RIGHTS AND DESERVES YOUR
EYEBALLS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ARE MOVING NOW TO
WITNESSES SO- MAYBE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WAS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY SEVEN.
TWENTY ONE HERE WISHES THIS
SPEAKER TESTIFIED ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL- SEEN NONE WILL MOVE
TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM- WE DO NOT
HAVE WITNESSES THEY'RE WAITING
TO SPEAK US WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR NASA MODERATOR. AT
THE POLICE QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN. THE END
UP PLEASE LET US KNOW HOW MANY
YOU HAVE IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU MISTER TURNER AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN GENERAL AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE ONE PARTY IN
THE QUEUE. OUR WITH ONE OTHER
TWENTY ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MATT BOBBY
AFTER THE CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- WE'RE GOING TO
NOTE MOVED TO OPPOSITION. IT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES-
UNDERSTAND THAT TO BE MATTHEW
ALLEN IN BRIAN LITTLE- MISTER
ALAN ARE YOU AVAILABLE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR GERM AVAILABLE CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE PROCEED
WE CAN REFINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE I
MATTHEW ALLEN WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN- SINCE IT'S FAR
MORE THAN A STRAIGHTFORWARD
NOTIFICATION BILL- OUR FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ON THE ISSUE OF-
TRAVEL TIME- THE BILL CHANGES A
LOT ON TRAVEL TIME TO CREATE
THE NEW RIGHT THAT IS CONTRARY
TO THE LONG STANDING ESTABLISH
JUDICIAL PRECEDENT- THE BILL
FALSELY STATE THAT IS
DECLARATORY THE EXISTING LAW.
WHEN IN REALITY THE BILL- IS
CHANGING A LOT ABOUT EXPANDING
DEFINITION OF VOLUNTARY AND
MANDATORY APPLE TIME. AS THE
CITED BY THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT IN BRILLIANT VERSUS ROPE
ASKING IN TWO THOUSAND. BY
DOING SO AB EIGHT EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN ADD NEW SITUATIONS WHERE
BY TRAVEL TIME WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO BE PAID TO THE H.
AWAY EMPLOYEE. ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL GOES WELL BEYOND EXISTING
COURT DECISIONS BY REQUIRING
THAT THE TRAVEL TIME BE PAID AT
THE REGULAR RATE OF PAY. IS NOT
UNNOTICED VISITING RIGHTS SINCE
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THAT
TRAVEL TIME DEBATE COMPLICATED
AT NO LESS THAN THE MINIMUM
WAGE. FINALLY AS REGARDS THE-
GOVERNOR NEWSOM VETO. THE BILL-
DOES SIGNIFICANTLY MAYOR S. B.
ELEVEN OH TWO FROM LAST YEAR
THAT WAS VETOED. I INTERVIEWED
A MESSAGE THE GOVERNOR DIRECTED
THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY TO DEVELOP
AND MAINTAIN. THE EMPLOYEE
NOTIFICATION TEMPLATE THAT WAS
CONTEMPLATED UNDER ELEVEN OH
TWO- SINCE THAT AS THAT PROCESS
THAT CAN BE MORE READILY- TAKEN
CONSIDERATION CHANGES AND EACH
TO A GOVERNING LAW. AND ANY
FUTURE COURT DECISIONS. WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S DIRECTION OUTLINED
IN THE BE THE MESSAGE. SHOULD
PROCEED AFFORD WITHOUT THE
INTERFERENCE OF EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY COMMENT TODAY. OKAY
THANK YOU A BRIAN LITTLE- HE
WOULD BE NEXT IF YOU'RE
AVAILABLE. KAREN CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN- AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
BRING A LITTLE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU WE
OPPOSE AB FIFTY SEVEN BECAUSE
IT MAKES UNNECESSARY AND COSTLY
CHANGES IN THE LAW THAT WILL
APPLY TO AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYERS
WHO TURNED TO THE H. TWO A.
TEMPORARY VISA PROGRAM TO
OBTAIN SUFFICIENT NUMBERS OF
EMPLOYEES TO OPERATE THEIR
FARMS. AB EIGHT FIVE SEVEN
CREATES A RIGHT THAT DOES NOT
EXIST IN CURRENT LAW AND
COMPOUNDS THE PROBLEM BY
REQUIRING EMPLOYERS TO NOTIFY
EMPLOYEES OF THIS NONEXISTENT
RIGHT WELL AB FIFTY SEVEN
FALSELY STATES THAT IT IS TO
CLEAR TORRENT EXISTING LAW IT
ACTUALLY CHANGES THE LAW BY
EXPANDING THE DEFINITION. OF
ONTARIAN MANDATED TRAVEL TIME
BOTH OF WHICH WERE DEFINED BY
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT OR
MORRELL PACKING IN TWO
THOUSAND. IF AB FIFTY SEVEN AS
NEW SITUATIONS WHEREBY TRAVEL
TIME BE REQUIRED TO BE PAID BY
H. TWO EMPLOYEES. FIFTY SEVEN
GOES WELL BEYOND REAL PACKING
BY REQUIRING THE TRAVEL TIME
BETWEEN AT THE REGULAR RATE OF
PAY. THIS IS ANOTHER INSTANCE
WHERE AB FIFTY SEVEN IS NOT
CLEAR TO THE EXISTING LAW.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES TO TRAVEL
TIME TO COMPENSATE AT NO LESS
THAN THE PPLICABLE MINIMUM
WAGE. AB FIFTY SEVEN REQUIRES
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS TO FURNISH
ANOTHER DISCLOSURE TO THE RICH
TO A EMPLOYEES OF THEIR
EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW. THIS ADDITIONAL
NOTICES REDUNDANT AND
UNNECESSARY BECAUSE H. TWO
EMPLOYEES ENJOY THE SAME RIGHTS
PROTECTIONS UNDER STATE FEDERAL
LAWS TO MEXICAN POLICE. FEDERAL
H. TWO A. PROGRAM WAS REQUIRE
EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE H. TWO
EMPLOYEES OF THE WRITTEN COPY
THE RICH TO A CONTRACT IN THEIR
NATIVE LANGUAGE BY THE FIRST
DAY OF WORK. INCLUDING
INFORMATION ABOUT READY TO PAY
BUT IT'S CALCULATING PAY AND
ALLOWANCES CLAIMED AS PART OF
THE MINIMUM WAGE INCLUDING MEAL
ALLOWANCES. FOR THE MORE THE
SPECIFIED INFORMATION THAT WAS
PROVIDED AND THE LAWS ARE
REQUIRED TO BE PROVIDED. TO
EACH TO EMPLOYEES UNDER THE LAW.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN THE SYSTEM.
SOME TO ASK ELEVEN A TWO FORMER
SENATOR BILL MINING FOR LAST
YEAR. WHICH IS VETOED BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. IN VETO
MESSAGE THE GOVERNOR DIRECTED
CALIFORNIA LABOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY TO DEVELOP
AND MAINTAIN. EMPLOYEE
NOTIFICATION TEMPLECOMBE
COMPLETED EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN. SINCE IT IS A PROCESS
THAT CAN BE MORE READILY TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION CHANGES IN
H. TO A GOVERNING LAW. AND ANY
FUTURE COURT DECISIONS. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AGENCY TO IMPLEMENT THE
GOVERNOR'S INSTRUCTIONS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- WE'RE
GOING TO. COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IN ASTOR SOON
HERE IN THE ROOM TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTY SEVEN. A
SCENE KNOWN COME FORWARD A WILL
MOVE TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM. TWO
ZERO FOUR ZERO SEE NOBODY
THERE. I WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR NEST MODERATOR IF-
THE MODERATOR HAS ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN IF SO PLEASE
LET US KNOW THE NUMBER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE FIVE IN
THE QUEUE. LINE FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN MIND FORTY. I'M THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
GO AHEAD BUT- AFTERNOON SURE
MEMBERS IS BACK A MOTHER WITH A
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION WHY
GREAT POWERS WE ARE RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. BY FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU COULD HAVE IT ON THE AFTER
UNITED FARM WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
BY TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ASHLEY
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. NINE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO HOME.
APOLOGIES I AM. READY FOR MY
PART AND THE SUPPORT LINE THIS
IS DADDY GRANDMA LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE F. T. W.
RUSSIAN STATE COUNCIL AND TRUMP
APART THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CALIBER TRICHET CHARACTER WITH
AGRICULTURAL. CALIFORNIA
AVERAGE YOU EIGHT I THINK YOU.
FINE FOR TWO YOU'RE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON LET THE HIGHS GET ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY WINEMAKERS
OF CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BALLOT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GO TO
BOIL TO BE HAPPY CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL IN CALIFORNIA
FRESH FRUIT ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU.
SORRY THANK YOU I'M GOING
FORWARD WHICH IS ASSET TO
FOLKS- TRY TO STAY IN THEIR
LANE OF THIS WHEN YOU'RE WE
CALL SUPPORT WITNESSES- WE ASK
THAT YOU SPEAK THEN WE CALL
POSITION WITNESSES WE US OUR
THAT IT'S ONLY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES SO- WE ARE GOING TO
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE NOW
SEE THEIR QUESTIONS CONCERNS
COMMENTS SOME. HE AND- SENATOR
LAYERED. I HAD A QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR CAN I ARE TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND. OR WHAT THIS BILL
WAS IS TRYING TO ADDRESS AND-
MATT IS THE THING I WAS TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND BETWEEN THE
DIFFERENT WITNESSES. IS IT MY
PREDECESSOR DID VERY SIMILAR
BILL LAST YEAR THAT WAS VETOED.
AND THE GOVERNOR HAD CERTAIN
EXPRESS THINGS HE SAID ABOUT
VETOING I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
THE STATUS IS OF HIS OWN
ADMINISTRATION DOING WHAT HE
SAID IN A VETO MESSAGE CAN COME
OF ALL WE HEARD IT FROM ONE OF
THE WITNESSES SAID THE CURIOUS
TO HEAR FROM YOU HOW YOU THINK
THIS BILL IS DIFFERENT AND HOW
IT ADDRESSES THE VETO MESSAGE
SO THAT. YOUR FEELING BETTER
ABOUT ITS PROSPECTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER THERE- IF WE
DON'T WORK WITH ADMINISTRATION
ON THIS BILL THE TRUSTED A
NUMBER OF AREAS I THINK THE
MOST CRITICAL ONE IS GIVEN THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER MORE
DISCRETION TO CHANGE OR UPDATE
THE MODEL NOTICE AND I CAN
UNDERSTAND FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
PERSPECTIVE- WHY WOULD BE AN
ISSUE- TO NOT GET THAT KIND OF
DISCRETION. AND I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL
COMPONENTS IN ADDITION TO
WORKING ON THE- THE CLARITY IN
THE GUIDANCE THAT WOULD BE
GIVEN AS TO WHAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED COMPENSABLE- TRAVEL
TIME AND NOT A COULD NOT ALSO
KEY COMPONENT IS THAT TO SAY.
TRANSLATIONS BONTA REVERSES
MANDATED WOLF HOW DO YOU DEFINE
THAT AND SO CERTAINLY WORKING
MORE CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN TERMS OF-
THAT KIND OF CLARITY- TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE NOT THAT THAT THAT
THE WEEKLY CASTANET
APPROPRIATELY OVER THOSE
WORKERS THAT TRULY ARE- TAKING
MANDATED A TRANSPORTATION FOR
ALL PRACTICAL PURPOSES. AND IS
HE DOING IS THIS ADMINISTRATION
DOING THAT TEMPLATE THAT HE
SUGGESTED IN THE VETO MESSAGE
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON. THAT
INCLUDING SOME OF THE
DEFINITIONS AS WELL. SO THIS
BILL MY BE IN ALL. AND OF A WAY
TO REACH TO THE- YES-
ABSOLUTELY I THINK THAT WE
HAVEN'T RECEIVED- A SENSE THAT-
THE- WE HAVE RECEIVED AS
SENSORS EITHER OR IN FACT THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE THE GUIDANCE
NEEDED MESSAGE WAS LAST
SEPTEMBER. AND WE'RE IN JUNE OF
THE NEXT YEAR AND THE TEMPLATE
HASN'T BEEN DONE THAT'S CORRECT
THAT IN SORT OF. DEFAULTS TO
YOUR BILL PRESS FORCING THE
ISSUE. ABSOLUTELY AND I THINK
THAT IT BUT IT'S NOT LIKE YOU
KNOW IT IS STILL VERY
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS PUTTING
THIS BILL IS PROVIDING THAT
VEHICLE- THAT OTHERWISE YOU
KNOW IT TOO IT WOULD
NECESSARILY OCCURRENCE I THINK
THAT. GIVEN THE FACT THAT-
SUBSEQUENT TO THE VETO- THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS BILL IS
GOING TO COMMUTE IS MOVING
FORWARD UNDER NEW VEHICLE- OF
THAT WE DID HAVE A VERY
POSITIVE CONVERSATIONS
GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION BUT
TO YOUR POINT I WOULDN'T
ANTICIPATE. THAT MOVEMENT WOULD
OCCUR ABSENT THE BILL. I NOT A
AND MISSED CHAIR JUST MAKE A
COMMENT. I THINK THAT EXCHANGE
MAKES THE CASE FOR THE BILL
HERE TODAY OF MY NORMAL WEIGHT
THE LATER IT GETS INTO SESSION
THE MORE I GET IRRITATED ABOUT
WORKS IN PROGRESS AND WE HAD
ONE ON THE- SENATE FLOOR LAST
WEEK FOR A LONG TIME- AND IT
AND YET I THINK THIS IS A
GENUINE CASE THAT. SORT OF
MAKES THE CASE FOR THAT BECAUSE
YOU ARE TRYING TO WORK THIS OUT
SO. I THINK THAT'S- GIVES US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SAY WE
SUPPORT THE WORKING OUT PART OF
THIS AND ALL BE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL WHEN WE GET TO
THAT. MOMENT THANK YOU- OTHER
COMMENTS CONCERNS QUESTIONS
CENTERED RUSSELL. THANK YOU
THANK THE AUTHOR VERY MUCH IN I
THANK THE- SENATOR FROM ARE YOU
MONTEREY OR SANTA CRUZ. EITHER
ONE OKAY THE MODERATE- AND I
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION-
THERE'S A NUMBER OF ISSUES ONE
IS. SOME OF THE LEGAL ISSUES
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE AND
I WAS REALLY GLAD TO SEE THE
EXCHANGE AND THAT YOU HELPING
CLARIFY THAT THAT PIECE. AND
THEN THERE'S THE PIECE OF HOW
IT IS THAT THESE WORKERS ARE
TREATED THAT WOULD PUSH US IN
THE DIRECTION OF HAVING TO COME
UP WITH ARE WE GIVEN THE KIND
OF GIVING THEM THE KIND OF
NOTICE AND INFORMATION THAT
THEY SHOULD HAVE. A AND THAT'S
BEEN I MEAN THIS PROGRAM HAS
BEEN IN PLACE FOR OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS I THINK- AND-
HAVING WHEN HE YOU KNOW MAKING
THAT CLEAR OVER THE YEARS IT'S
OVER AND OVER IF SUCH
RESISTANCE THAT THESE WORKERS
WHO COME IN FROM ANOTHER
COUNTRY SERIOUSLY DO YOU THINK
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE TO BE ABLE TO REPORT
THIS OR THAT OR ASK QUESTIONS
THEY HAVE TO BE GIVEN THAT TO
THEM IN THE WAY THAT. THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'LL BE
COMPLETELY PROTECTED FROM THAT
AND THE ISSUE OF THE
TRANSPORTATION I REMEMBER AND
THIS IS MANY MANY YEARS AGO THE
DIFFERENCES AMONGST US EVERY
WORK ON THE FIELD BETWEEN THOSE
WHO WERE HERE AND THOSE WHO ARE
BEING OR BEING BROUGHT IN FROM
ANOTHER COUNTRY THE DIFFERENCES
IN THE WAY THEY WERE WE WERE
TREATED- AND ESPECIALLY ON THE
ISSUE OF TRANSPORTATION BECAUSE
HIS DON'T GO TO THE CORNER AND
SAM TO TAKE YOU KNOW NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT DOWN THE THIS
FIELDER THIS ORCHARD. I MEAN
YOU'RE COMPLETELY COMPLETELY AT
THE DISPOSAL OF WHEN WHERE HOW
ALL OF THAT IS DONE- BY THE
EMPLOYER SO- THERE'S BOTH THE
PRACTICAL SIDE- AND THE MORAL
SIDE AND THEN THERE'S OF COURSE
THE LEGAL ISSUES THAT YOU HAVE
TO ADDRESS SO. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR. BRINGING THIS FORWARD
FOR ON SO MANY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS. OKAY
ANYTHING ELSE MEMBERS SERVE
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE. I'M SEEN
NONE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU'RE
WALKING CLOSE IF YOU LIKE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
APPRECIATE THE CALL TO
QUESTIONS REGARDING THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION AND-
TO FOLLOW UP ON OUR- SENATORS
ARE SO WHO. I'M VERY HAPPY TO
HAVE THIS PIECE OF CLOTH ON
THIS BILL THE REALITY IS THAT
EMPLOYER PROVIDED
TRANSPORTATION IS A CRITICAL
ELEMENT OF THE BUSINESS MODEL.
OF OF THE GROWERS IN A ON THE
AUTOPLAY PARKING FACILITIES
PEOPLE COME AND GO ON THEIR
TIME IN THEIR SCHEDULE AND
THAT'S FINE- BUT LET'S NOT CALL
VOLUNTARY BUT THIS IS NOT LIKE-
SPEAKING OF SILICON VALLEY WITH
A CHAIR AND I HELD FROM. THE
GOOGLE AND APPLE EMPLOYEE
LIVING IN SAN FRANCISCO HAVING
A CHOICE TO DRIVE TAKE CALTRAIN
OR OR TAKE THE COMPANY OF A
BUS. TO THE TO WORK- IT'S OF
IT'S A QUITE TO THE CONTRARY
THE ONLY VOLUNTARY ASPECT OF
THIS THEY CAN CHOOSE TO GO ON
THE BUS AND GO TO WORK FOR THE
COUNTRY'S TEN OUT OF A JOB. AND
SO THE REALITY IS THAT THIS IS.
REALLY WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE- RELEASED UP. NOT JUST
NOTICE- BUT COMPANY. AND MANNER
THAT ACTUAL. WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN REAL WORLD. AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S WHAT OUR FARMWORKERS
DESERVE AND THAT'S WHAT.
DIGNITY AND THAT'S WHAT THE
LAW- FRANKLY DICTATES FOR US TO
ACT UPON AND SO. WITH THAT-
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE IN THIS YEAR'S GREAT TO
HAVE. A COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
JOSE'S CHAIRING THIS COMMITTEE
NUMBER PRODUCT. THANK YOU SO WE
WERE. UP CENTER LAYERED ON WERE
YOU IN IN TO MAKE THE MOTION.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION IN
THE LS AT THE ROLL CALL BECAUSE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. SENATORS PROTESTING
ALL RIGHT OR TO THE I A SHRUB
OAK. THE RESTAURANT HI. I AIRED
HI I NEWMAN HI. NEWMAN NINE THE
VOTERS FOR. THE BILL EVEN
THOUGH THE. VOTED NO ASSURE
BUCKNER WAS FOUR TO ONE THE
BILLS OUT THANK YOU. THE NEXT
UP WE HAVE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FORTY FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ WELCOME. WELCOME TO
YES PLEASE- PRESENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WOULD BE EIGHT
FORTY FIVE WILL CREATE A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION FOR
CERTAIN FRONT LINE WORKERS THAT
A COVERT NINETEEN RELATED
ILLNESS CONTRACTED ON THE JOB
TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR IN SERVICE
DISABILITY RETIREMENT. THE
PROPOSAL BUT WILL PRESENT
PRESUMPTION WOULD BE IN EFFECT
UNTIL JULY TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
THESE EMPLOYEES INCLUDE
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
FIREFIGHTERS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND PUBLIC SERVANTS TO JUST TO
NAME A FEW. THIS BILL WOULD TO
FINANCIALLY PROTECT THOSE WHO
HAVE HELPED KEEP OUR LIGHTS ON
OUR WATER RUNNING OUR FOOD
STOCKS AND TREAT OUR ILLNESSES
AS WELL AS OUR LOVE ONES. IN
THE MIDST OF THE PANDEMIC. WITH
ME TODAY THIS TERRY BURNETT
REPRESENTING SA YOU TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT AND SPEAK TO ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
I WANT TO HEAR THE FACT. THAT
YEAH I WOULD. I DON'T KNOW HOW
TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT ANYTHING.
WE GET A SHOT MISTER BROWN
PLEASE PROCEED THE STAFF JERRY
BROWN AND WITH THE FBI
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL PICKS UP
WHERE ELEVEN FIFTY NINE LAST
YEAR LEFT OFF ONCE YOU'VE GONE
THROUGH QUALIFIED FOR WORKERS
COMP GOING TO THE MEDICAL
OCCUPATIONAL REHAB AND IF FOR
SOME REASON YOU CANNOT RETURN
TO WORK AND YOU HAVE TO TAKE A
DISABILITY RETIREMENT. YOU'RE
UNDER THIS BILL AWARDED THE
EXACT SAME PRESUMPTION SHE
WOULD UNDER THE WORKERS COMP
LAW AS IT CURRENTLY STANDS
THAT'S WHAT EXPIRES AT THE SAME
TIME- AND- WE ARE DRIVE VOTE WE
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THE LONG HAUL
PROSPECTS ARE OF A- THE FAX OF
COVETED BUT- AT LEAST FOR THOSE
WHO ARE DISABLED AND HAVE TO
FILE IN THIS TIME PERIOD. THEY
WON'T HAVE TO GO BACK AND RE
PROVE THAT IT WAS WORK RELATED
DISABILITY. FOR THAT REASON WE
ARE CHEN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
OKAY YOU FOR TO. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE HERE COMMITTEE ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHT FORTY FIVE. THE C.
KNOWN COME FORWARD WILL LOOK TO
THE OVERFLOW ROOM. OTHER IN A
WITNESSES THERE TO TESTIFY WILL
GO TO THE MODERATOR MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES ON AB
EIGHT FORTY FIVE AND LET US
KNOW THE NUMBER PLEASE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE CURRENTLY HAVE THREE IN THE-
I'M SORRY WE HAVE FOUR IN THE
COMIC YOU CURRENTLY. KILLING
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTY BELMONT HERE
ON BEHALF. OF THIRTY THOUSAND
FIREFIGHTERS EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES PERSONNEL CALIFORNIA
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. JUST TO BE BRIEF BUT
STILL PROVIDES THE PROPERTY
INSURANCE TO THE MEN AND WOMEN
FIRE SERVICE AND ALL OTHER
SOCIAL WORKERS WHO PAID A
TERRIBLE PRICE FOR THEIR
SERVICE. I CAN RETIRE WITH AN
INSERVICE OUR NATIONAL
DISABILITY. RETIREMENT WE ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. ONE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THIRTY NINE YOUR
MIND IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THIRTY NINE YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM I'M
THIRTY NINE I JUST OF THE FIVE.
ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THIS IS ENSURE RIGHT BUT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM IN SUPPORT.
NINE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS COPE QUERY WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FORTY FIVE. NINE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS BRANDON UP ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF
IN SUPPORT. THE MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT- ON THE TELECONFERENCE.
ONE WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
ANNA OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WILL COME BACK TO OPPOSITION
UNDERSTAND THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS. AND NOBODY
IS CORRECTING ME ON THAT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
IN THIS COMMITTEE ROOM A SCENE
NINE OTHERS KNOWN IN THE
OVERFLOW ROOM TO TESTIFY ON THE
BILL. I WILL GO BACK TO THE
MODERATOR IN ASK YOU TO PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION.
TESTIMONY ON AB EIGHT FORTY
FIVE AND LET US KNOW THE NUMBER
WITNESSES PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT
FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE DO HAVE LINE FORTY FIVE.
ALTHOUGH I THINK NINE FORTY
FIVE WAS QUEUED UP IN THE
SUPPORT ONE MOMENT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FORTY FIVE. SORRY
ABOUT THAT I WAS TAKEN OUT OF
HUMAN SUPPORT THIS IS JENNIFER
NALLEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE. WE HAVE NO COMMENT IN THE
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN THAT
CASE WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OF FOR QUESTIONS
CONCERNS BROUGHT UP BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS COMMENTS.
BILL HE WANTS TO BE MOVED BY
SENATOR NEWMAN WILL GIVE THE-
AUTHOR AN OPPORTUNITY CLOSE IF
YOU LIKE CORRECT STRICTLY AS
PRIVATE THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU CENTER NEWMAN- HAS MOVED
THE BILL AND TO A LESSER
CONSULTANT TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS FOR TESTING ALL RIGHT
OR TO THE I. OR SHOW A BOOK.
RUSSIA BURKE I DID I SAW. THE
DRESS I LAYERED HI THERE I
NEWMAN HI. BERMAN I THAT MOST
PASS FAST THE BILL WAS FIVE TWO
ZERO SO THE BILLS ARE THANK YOU.
HINDER ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE HAVE
YOU NEXT UP FOR AB TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE- YOU MAY PROCEED
WITH PRESENTATION WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ONCE AGAIN TURN MEMBERS SB
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE WOULD
PROMOTE EARN AND LEARN TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES BY DOING TWO
THINGS. FIRST IT WOULD AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS TO THE INTERAGENCY
COUNCIL ON APPROACH FROM SHIP
STANDARDS AS THESE DEPARTMENTS
CAN POSITIVELY IMPACT BURNER
AND OPPORTUNITIES. SECOND THIS
BILL TO PROHIBIT THESE
DEPARTMENTS FROM DISCOURAGING
OR NO LEARN OPPORTUNITIES.
THERE APPEARS TO BE NO GOOD
REASON NOT TO ALLOW TRAINEES TO
EARN A WAGE FOR THE WORK THEY
DO. THESE RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
INCLUDED IN A REPORT PUBLISHED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS WHICH REQUIRED BY MINE
BILL AB TWENTY ONE OH FIVE IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. AT A TIME
WHEN HEALTH CARE WORKERS ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED TO SAVE OUR
POPULATION THIS BILL WOULD HELP
BRIDGE THAT CONNECTION. BETWEEN
STUDENTS AND EMPLOYERS AND
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE FROM DIVERSE
ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS TO JOIN
THIS WORKFORCE. CALLING THEM TO
TESTIFY TODAY AND SUPPORT IS
NOT LAKE REPRESENTING SEIU.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THAT THE
MISTER LAKE IF YOU'D LIKE YOU
KNOW YOU MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THAT MATT WAS A ON
BEHALF OF THAT SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE. THREE WHICH WOULD
PROMOTE EARN AND LEARN TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA-
PERSON JUST BY CLICKING OFF
THEIR PERCH CONTINUED
DEDICATION. THE BAND SPENT
EARNING MY PROGRAMS AND HOW
FASHION. CALIFORNIA HAVE A
GROWING SHORTAGE OF HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS CURRENTLY SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS THE VAST
MAJORITY LATINO BLACK AND
NATIVE AMERICANS LIVE IN THAT
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE
AREA. OUR HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
NEEDS ARE EXPECTED TO GROW WITH
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF NEWLY
TRAINED HEALTHCARE WORKERS
NEEDED TO MEET THE DEMAND OF
AGING AND DIVERSE POPULATION.
SORT SHORTAGES OF HEALTH
WORKERS- LEAD TO DELAYS IN CARE
WORSENING HEALTH OUTCOMES
BECAUSE THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC-
HIS TAKING A TOLL ON HER HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE WHICH 30% OF
HEALTHCARE. WORKERS CONSIDERING
LEAVING THE PROFESSION. THIS
COUPLED WITH ONE OF NURSES IN
PHYSICIAN OVER THE AGE OF FIFTY
FIVE MEANING THAT THEIR LIKELY
MEANING THESE TRENDS ARE LIKELY
TO GET WORSE HE- TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE UP TO ADDRESS RESTRAINED
BY ELIMINATING BARRIERS. AND
MARK WILLIAMS INTO OUR
PROFESSIONS. COPLEY'S ARE. TO
ENSURE THE INDIVIDUALS WITH
FAMILY COMMITMENTS ARE ECONOMIC
BARRIERS ARE ABLE TO ADVANCE MY
CAREER. FOR EXAMPLE I'M JUST
ONE OF THESE PROFESSIONS SUCH
AS THE X. RAY TECHNOLOGISTS IT
REQUIRES ALMOST TWO THOUSAND
HOURS OF CLINICAL TRAINING
WHICH IS ALMOST ALWAYS ON PAGE-
THAT IS EIGHT HOURS A DAY OVER
TWO YEARS I'M HE WORK. THIS IS
A BURDEN THAT FALLS
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON THOSE
WITHOUT SOCIAL SUPPORTS.
APARTMENTS SUCH AS THIS BECAUSE
SOME FUTURE HEALTH CARE WORKERS
TO EITHER GIVE UP ON THEIR
DREAM OF BECOMING A HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL OR TWO GOING TO
SUBSTANTIAL THAT. AS A MEMBER
OF THE EIGHTY TWENTY ONE OH
FIVE COMMITTEE- WHICH PRODUCED
THE REPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ I MENTIONED- THIS
GROUP INCLUDES STAKEHOLDERS
FROM ACROSS THE INDUSTRY ONE OF
THE KEY FINDINGS WITH THAT
LICENSE BOARDS DO NOT ALWAYS
HAVE A PROHIBITION ORDER LEARN
PROGRAMS. HOWEVER MANY OF THESE
ACCREDITING- BODIES DO- THAT
THE BOARD'S RYAN ON- FOR THESE
REASONS- WE WOULD LIKE TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS A PATHWAY
FOR EVERYONE TO BECOME A HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK. FOR YOUR I. OKAY THANK YOU
YOUR TESTIMONY- WE'RE GONNA
COME BACK COMMITTEE ROOMS IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE
ROOM THAT WISHES TO SPEAK. UP
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL SEE NONE
THE BACK TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM-
WE HAVE NO WITNESSES THERE-
PUSHING TO TESTIFY. WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE MODERATOR. IN THE
ASK YOU TO PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
SUPPORT WITNESSES ON. AB.
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE AND PLEASE
LET US KNOW THE NUMBER OF
WITNESSES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
DO HAVE ONE CURRENTLY IN THE
COMING Q. FINE FORTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HELLO THOUSAND A JEWISH
VOCATIONAL SERVICES I DON'T
REMEMBER THE TWENTY ONE OH FIVE
TEN FOUR IN CURRENTLY SAID ON
IRAQ COULD WORK WITH. THE
INCLUDED BREAK DOWN THE
BARRIERS THAT LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. ACT LIMITED TO A
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU CHRI THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. BUT NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN THE QUEUE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT-
WE WILL GO TO LEAD OPPOSITION.
AND FOR THAT TO UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE LNN ROY AND WILL ADVANCE
IS LYNNE ROY AVAILABLE. YES ALL
RIGHT PLEASE PROCEED. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS WHEN
ROY REPRESENTING THE PACIFIC
SOUTHWEST CHAPTER TECHNOLOGY
SECTION OF THE SOCIETY OF
NUCLEAR MEDICINE AND MOLECULAR
IMAGING WE APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
SUBMITTING A LETTER IN ADVANCE
BUT WERE NOT AWARE OF THE BILL
AND PACKED INTO VERY RECENTLY
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE UNLESS
AMENDED NUCLEAR MEDICINE
TECHNOLOGISTS INJECTS
RADIOACTIVE PHARMACEUTICALS AND
OTHER PHARMACEUTICALS TO ELICIT
A PHYSIOLOGICAL METABOLIC
RESPONSE IN PATIENTS. IMAGES
ARE TAKEN OF THAT HIGH DOSES OF
BREAKING PROMISES BECAUSE ALSO
GIVEN TO SPECIFICALLY TARGET
TREAT NOTHING CAN CANCER.
MEDICINES CLOSER ACCREDITED BY
THE JOINT REVIEW COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION AND NUCLEAR MEDICINE
TECHNOLOGY ACCREDITATION
ASSURES THAT PROGRAMS MEET
ACCEPTABLE LEVELS OF QUALITY
FOR A COMPREHENSIVE PEER
REVIEWED EVALUATION AND
ACCREDITED PROGRAMS TAUGHT AT
THE COLLEGE LEVEL USUALLY
REQUIRING ABOUT A HUNDRED
TWENTY HOURS TO COMPLETE
COURSES INCLUDE PHYSICS
CHEMISTRY MOLECULAR BIOLOGY
RADIATION BIOLOGY COMPUTERIZED
TOMOGRAPHY AND PHARMACOLOGY TO
NAME A FEW. MANY OF THESE ARE
UPPER LEVEL CLASSES WILL BE
DIFFICULT TO TEACHERS AT THE
APPRENTICE LEVEL IN ADDITION
ONE MUST GADUATE FROM AN
ACCREDITED NO PROMOTION PROGRAM
IN ORDER TO SET THE NATIONAL
CERTIFICATION FOR THE NUCLEAR
MEDICINE TECHNOLOGIST
CERTIFICATION BOARD. AB TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE APPEARS TO NOT
RECOGNIZE ACCREDITING
INSTITUTIONS A NOT. A LOT WE
JUST. DON'T J. R. C. N. M.
POWER PROHIBITS STUDENTS
ANYWHERE TOOK OUR ASIDE TO
PROTECT TO QUIT TRAINING SITES
TO STUDENTS. THE P. OF
CERTIFIED TAX IN THE MANY RELY
SEPT. CAL SENATE CREDITED FOR
PERSONAL BECAUSE IS AN EMPTY
DOES NOT ALIVE STUDENTS TO BE
PAID. CALIFORNIA NUCLEAR
MEDICINE STUDENTS WOULD NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO TAKE THE NMTC
BE NATIONAL CERTIFICATION
BOARD. BUT COULD NOT BE HIGHER
THAN ANY OTHER STATE TO PERFORM
NUCLEAR MEDICINE AS NATIONAL
CERTIFICATION IS REQUIRED IN
MOST STATES. TRAINING
INSTITUTIONS OPERATING AT NEAR
ZERO MAR MARGIN'S MAY CANCEL
THEIR CLINICAL AFFILIATIONS
ALTHOUGH VERY WELL INTENDED
THIS BILL COULD HAVE MAJOR
CONSEQUENCES TO THOSE
PROFESSIONS THAT REQUIRE
COLLEGE DEGREES. NATIONAL
CERTIFICATION AND ACCREDITING
BOARD DID NOT ALLOW WAGES TO BE
PAID. THE CIVIC CENTER PRESS
CHAPTER URGES YOU TO RECONSIDER
GOING FORWARD WITH THIS
LEGISLATION WITHOUT AMENDMENT
AT THE IMPACT. OF THIS BILL
WOULD BE FAR REACHING. WHO
THANK YOU. DIDN'T MR ADMIN ARE
YOU. TO IT CERTAINLY AMERICA
YES WE CAN DO MAY PROCEED. OKAY
PICTURE GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
WILLIAMS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGISTS AS ITS
CURRENT PRESIDENT. THE C. S. R.
T. REPRESENTS OVER TEN THOUSAND
LICENSED RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGIST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO APOLOGIZE
FOR NOT SUBMITTING A LETTER OF
OPPOSITION THE MAPS BUT WE WERE
JUST BECAME AWARE OF THIS BILL.
RECENTLY WE STAND RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED WAS AMENDED TO EARN AND
LEARN CONCEPT MISSIONS AND THIS
BILL. THIS BILL SIMILAR TO ONE
PUT FORTH TWO YEARS AGO AB.
THREE SEVEN WHICH WAS
SUCCESSFULLY DEFEATED. THE
ACTUAL WORK EXPERIENCES BEING
FOR AT A PRE LIFE. RUBBLE AHEAD
OF NATIONAL BOARD REGISTERED
WITH THE MEDICAL IMAGING WHICH
PLACES THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA. AT JEOPARDY OF
BEING IMPROPERLY EXPOSED TO
IONIZING RADIATION I AM LICENSE
STUDENTS. STUDENTS HAVE TO BE
PROPERLY SUPERVISING CANNOT
WORK INDEPENDENTLY. THERE'S NO
CLARITY ON HOW TO EARN CONCEPT
IS DEFINED IN THE REGULATIONS
CLINICAL TRAINING SITES. COULD
HAVE TO PAY DAMAGING STUDENTS
FOR THEIR TIME SPENT DURING THE
REQUIRED PROGRAM HOURS IN A
HOSPITAL SETTING. THIS
REGISTERED COULD NOT COULD BE
PAID FOR RUNNING A GREAT IN A
COLLEGE COURSE BOTH THE CSU AND
UC HAVE PROPOSED THIS TYPE OF
PAYMENT. THE FOR COLLEGE HAVE
TO PAY THE STUDENT WHILE
LEARNING. THIS BECAUSE TUITION
TO GO UP SO BASED ON WHERE THE
FUNDING COMES FROM. SCHOOLS
WOULD LOSE CRITICAL SITES FOR
THOSE NOT WILLING TO PAY FOR
STUDENTS TO LEARN. WELL FEES
PAID BY STUDENTS WOULD GO UP.
THEM BACK TO THIS BILL CALLS
INTO QUESTION THE ABILITY.
MEDIC QUICKLY BASED HEALTH
SCIENCE PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO MAINTAIN THE HIGHEST
LEVEL. OF NATIONALLY BASED
ACADEMIC ACCREDITATION AND
LICENSURE BUT TO PROTECT. THE
PATIENT POPULATION CALIFORNIA.
STRONGLY BELIEVE THIS BILL
WOULDN'T. ACCESS OUR FINANCE. A
THE STATE AND WE'RE THE SPOT SO.
OF QUALIFIED HEALTH PROVIDERS
NEEDED TO MEET THE GROWING
DEMAND WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED WORKING
TOGETHER ON ALTERNATVE
SOLUTIONS. THAT CAN HELP
PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY TO STUDENTS
WITH THE SAME LEVEL OF
ACCREDITATION. WILL MEET THE
GROWING DEMAND FOR ADEQUATELY
PREPARED IN LICENSE GRADUATES
READY TO JOIN THE HEALTHCARE
PROFESSION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME THE TIME TO
SPEAK TODAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WILL COME BACK
COMMITTEE RUMORS OR ANYBODY WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWELVE SEVENTY THREE HERE
IN THE CMMITTEE ROOM IS SO.
PLEASE COME FORTH. YOU HAVE TO
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO NAME
AFFILIATION AND- YOUR SUPPORT-
YEARS OPPOSITION POSITION
EVIDENTLY THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
CHRISTY FOSTER BOWMAN I'M THE
EXECUTIVE PROGRAM DIRECTOR. FOR
RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGY AT
GARNOCK ACADEMY MEDICAL ARTS. I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE. A SEEN
NONE WILL CHECK YOUR FOR ROOM
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE THERE
THERE IS NOT. WILL COME BACK TO
THE MODERATOR NESS MODERATOR TO
QUEUE UP ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
AB TWELVE SEVENTY THREE AND
PLEASE LET US KNOW THE NUMBER
WITNESSES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN THERE. WE HAVE NOBODY
IN THE QUEUE. OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- FOR ANY CONCERNS OR
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME. AS SEEN
NONE OF WILL COME BACK TO THE
AUTHOR FOR AN OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE- BOTH THE RENTALS SHARE
THE CONCERNS OF OUR- TOP
POSITION AS OF THE- THEY JUST
CAME TO US LAST LATE LAST WEEK.
SO LOOK FOR TO WORKING THEM AND
SEEING WHAT THEIR CONCERNS ARE
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD.
HOPEFULLY ALL ABOUT TRYING TO
PROVIDE MORE HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS NOT LAST WITHOUT
PERSPECTIVES FOR A VOTE THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU SO MEMBER-
IS THERE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
MOTION BY SENATOR NEWMAN A
WEAKENED A CALL FOR ROLL CALL
VOTE AT THIS TIME PLUS CONSOLE
TO DO THAT THANK YOU. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH CENTER COURTESY ALL
RIGHT. BUT TO THE I. CENTERS A
TROUBLED. THE TROUBLE GUY
WRESTLE. RUSSELL I LAYERED HI
THERE I NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN
I. THANK YOU THAT THE VOTE
COUNT WAS FIVE TWO ZERO
UNANIMOUS- SO THE BILL IS A-
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
WHO MOVE ON NOW TO. AB. SIX
SIXTEEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
WELCOME. YOU MAY PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE PREPARED TO DO
SO THANK YOU. SENATORS AV SIX
ONE SIX IS A PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL THAT IS
MODERNIZING FARMWORKERS
ELECTIONS JUST AS WE HAVE
LEARNED THAT MAIL IN BALLOTS
ARE VERY EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE WAY OF ENSURING
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR
VOTE THIS IS A PROCEDURE THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE FORMER WORKER
INSTEAD OF JUST GOING TO A
POLLING PLACE WHICH IS USUALLY.
AT A- AT THE END AGRICULTURAL
FACILITY THEY COULD CHOOSE TO
TAKE THAT BALLOT. MARKET
THEMSELVES MAIL IT THE BALLOT
WOULD BE SEALED IN AN ENVELOPE
THAT IS PROVIDED BY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER AND MAILED
DIRECTLY TO THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER SO IT STILL IS A
SECRET BALLOT THAT IS A VERY.
IMPORTANT PROVISIONS IN THIS
LEGISLATION SO THEY WOULD HAVE
AN OPTION VOTER TO POLLING
PLACES LIKE WE'RE USED TO
FURTHER ELECTIONS WAR HAVE A
MAIL IN BALLOT WHICH IS VERY
VERY CONVENIENT. THEY COULD
TAKE THE BALLOT THEY DON'T HAVE
TO MAIL IT IN THEY CAN
CERTAINLY MAIL IT IN IF THEY
WANT TO OR THEY CAN STILL VOTE
IN A POLLING PLACE. IT'S JUST
THAT PROCEDURE. SO IT'S FAIRLY
STRAIGHTFORWARD- WITH ME I HAVE
TO RESET ROMERO FROM THE U. S.
W. THE PRESENCE OF U. F. W. AND
WE ALSO HAVE A LINE MARIO
MARTINEZ WHOSE GENERAL COUNSEL
YOU HAVE TO BE. WAS AVAILABLE
TO ASK ANY QUESTIONS AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHERE
AN ITEM. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MANY MEMORABLE MOVED TO
TERESA ROMERO FROM UNITED FARM
WORKERS- IF YOUR BILL WILL BE.
HE MADE CUT BEGIN TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE COULD
AFTERNOON. AGAIN MY NAME
SACRAMENTO AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS. I
DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE A
REGULATION ACT WHICH WAS
ENACTED IN JULY NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. NUMBER BEGINNING
A PERCENTAGE REDUCTIONS ARE
CONDUCTED BUT BRING THEM IN
CONNECTION BURKE CONDUCTED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE. IN
PERSON AT A PHYSICAL MODEL.
THEY THANK THE WAIT TIME FOR
ANY CONDUCT. PROCESS HAS
EVOLVED AND CHANGED IN ORDER TO
INCREASE PARTICIPATION.
DESTRUCTION REGISTER WITH YOUR
BODY THEIR- TIME EVERYONE HAS
BROUGHT HAS INCREASED. THIS CAN
I LOVE SOMEONE ELSE JOINING THE
BALLOT IN CALIFORNIA'S VOTING
CHARMS AT HAS CREATED OPTIONS.
FOR HOW PEOPLE CAN CAST A
BALLOT. DEAFENING ISN'T SAYING
AND I QUOTE I CAN MAKING VOTING
EASIER PROVIDING OR CHARLIE FOR
TWENTY. FIVE MINUTES WHAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC ROTENBERG
LEADERSHIP AND AN EIGHTY SIX
POINT SIX. THAT OKAY
PUBLICATION. AT TWELVE. IT IS
DIVERTING INTERPRETATION. ABOUT
REMAIN SECRET AMERICANS WILL
HAPPEN. AT BAD PHYSICAL. I
THINK YOU OR THEY CAN FILL OUT
A REPRESENTATION BALLOT CARD.
WE WERE FILLING OUT THE CARD
THE PERSON WHO IS GOOD
PRESENTATION BALLOT CARD IN THE
BALLOT CARD TRYING TO BE. LET
ME OPEN NINE. JEFF DONALD NOW A
VOTERS MAKING. ALEX BUT THE
PROPOSED JUST. WHEN HE WAS SICK
OF. AND HIS APPOINTMENT EFFORT
WHAT ARE FINAL RESPECT THING
DECIDING THEIR FUTURES FREE
FROM ANY FORM OF BOTH
SUPPRESSION WE ASK. FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
WILL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ROOM AT THIS TIME AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX ONE SIX SEE
NO ONE IN THE ROOM STEPPING
FORWARD WILL LOOK AT THE-
OVERFLOW ROOM OTHER NO SPEAKERS
THERE- TO TESTIFY. I WILL GO
BACK TO THE MODERATOR NESS
MODERATELY QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES FOR AB SIX ONE SIX
PLEASE LET US KNOW THE NUMBER
OF WITNESSES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIX ONE SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
ONE SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT WE DO
HAVE TWO PARTIES IN THE QUEUE.
NINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MARK SHOCKER
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WAVE OF THE PHANTOMS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT. MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT OKAY THANK
YOU- MOVING NOW TO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES MY UNDERSTANDING IS-
WE HAVE TWO OF THEM ASHLEY
HOFFMAN IN MATTHEW ALLEN HI
MISS HOFFMAN ARE YOU. PREPARED
TO TESTIFY. YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
ALRIGHT PLEASE PROCEED THEM.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HASN'T
ACTUALLY HAFID ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION EIGHTY SIX POINT
SIX AS A JOB KILLER A PRESENTLY
UNION ALEXION ARGUES THAT
PROFIT FROM AGRICULTURE
SPENDING THERE'S AN INTERESTING
UNION STATION EMPLOYEE FIND A
PETITION AND THE MAJORITY OF
THEM PLEASE FIND THAT THAT YOU
SHOULD BE A. R. P. AT SEVEN
MONITORS A FEW QUICK BALLOT
ELECTION. THERE ARE MULTITUDE
OF REASONS BINDING PLAY MAKES
BUT INTERESTS AND FIND A
POSITION THAT ULTIMATELY DECIDE
NOT TO BROKER WE GET YET ALSO
INCREDIBLY BOTH SIDES HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT POTENTIAL
MISCONDUCT WHEN IT COMES UNION
ELECTION CAMPAIGN. FOR THAT
REASON THAT THE THINK ABOUT
PROCESS HAS LONG BEEN SUPPORTED
BYTHE A. R. B. AND R. B. AND
OTHERS THAT KNOWLEDGE IN THAT
IT IS THE MOST ACCURATE
REFLECTION OF THE EMPLOYEES WHO
DESIRES WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WANT TO UNIONIZE THE PUBLIC FOR
THAT REASON THAT THE ARB AND
OUR BEHALF SOCIAL GROUP IN
PLACE TO PHYSICALLY ELIMINATE
LAST MINUTE PRESSURING ELECTION
HEARING. BILL WOULD HAVE
DESTROYED THE PROTECTION
AGAINST CORROSION BY
ELIMINATING THE SECTORS THAT
THE THINK ABOUT THAT AND ALSO
IN THE BOOK REGION BY ALLOWING
THE UNIT TO FILL OUT THE
REPRESENTATION BALLOT CARD FOR
THE EMPLOYEE NEARLY GETS
REQUIRING THE EMPLOYEE. TO FIND
AFTER ITS PRE FILLED OUT FOR
THAT. THE BILL HAD CALLED
CONSERVE ABOUT THE- HIGH
PROFILE. ONE THE PRESIDENT AND
THE LEADING CONNECTED- AND WORK
SELECT CAMPAIGN AND DECISION
REPORTER BY THE A. R. B. I. R.
B. AND THE COURT THAT CONDUCT
INCLUDING CLAIMS YOU KNOW
REPRESENT PRESS EMPLOYEES
BEHIND CHAMBER BUT A CERTAIN
RIGHT AND THEN THEY CAN MOVE
THEIR JOB. AND INCLUDE YOUR
BILL LET THEM IT INCLUDES
BRIGHTENING OF THE THAT WITH
THE AND ALSO INCLUDES THE USE
OF METHODS SUCH AS THE WRITTEN
ACCORDING TO PLAY FOR YOUR-
WHEN FACT EMPLOYERS COULD IT
HAVE NEVER MADE SUCH STATE AND
DIDN'T OCCUR. ON THE FIRES.
EVEN THAT ONE. ON THE TO FIVE
IF I JUST NATURALLY MARC WITH
THE GOAL OF THE TAKE A- CON. TO
THE PERSON. BUT YOU ME BUY A
PRE FILLED CAR. RECESSION
WITHOUT IS A WORKER OR SOMEONE
A POSITION POWER. THE
AGRICULTURE STATE EVEN. OFF
TRAVEL. SURE HOW. THE FARMER
APPLICTION FOR IN. OR COERCION
AND INTO. WE DO BELIEVE IT IS.
TO SAY THAT THE FIFTY IS SIMPLY
CHEMICAL. ELECT HELLO MAIL AND-
A SECRET BALLOT PROVIDE BEING.
TO CAST THEIR- IN PRICE WITH
PRESSURE RECORD. GIVEN THE OF
TO KEEP THEIR VOTE GREAT THEY
SO. RENDON RIGHT WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO ECLIPSE
SIX ONE SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- MATTHEW
ALLEN ARE YOU AVAILABLE TO
TESTIFY. I AM HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE I
MATTHEW OUT WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION HOW WE
WOULD A READER RIGHT THAT THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE- WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO AB SIX ONE SIX. AT
THE VERY HEART OF THE ADEQUATE
RELATIONS. ACT IS THE GUARANTEE
THAT EMPLOYEES HAVE THE ARE TO
THEIR CHOI WITH THIS TO YOU
REPRESENTS TO A SECRET. BALLOT.
ALEXION THIS IS EXTRAORDINARILY
PROBLEMATIC SIMPLY SHOULD
REMAIN FREE TO VOTE THEIR
CONSCIENCE IN A SECRET BALLOT
ELECTION WHERE NEITHER THE
EMPLOYER OR THE UNION. BOTH OF
WHICH HAVE A FINANCIAL INTEREST
IN THE OUTCOME CAN INFLUENCE
OUR OBSERVER THERE ABOUT-
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BONDING REQUIREMENT AND
HAVE OUTLINED IN THE BILL- WHEN
APPEALING CERTAIN DECISIONS OF
THE L. R. B. AS A VIOLATION
IMPLORES BASIC DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS. IT IS FOR THESE REASONS
THAT WE THAT WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU MISTER ON TERM WE'RE GONNA
COME BACK TO COMMITTEE ROOM AND
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO AB SIX
ONE SIX. THE SCENE NO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES COME
FORWARD. WILL TURN TO THE
OVERFLOW ROOM AND ASKS FOR
TESTIMONY THERE ARE THERE ARE
NO WITNESSES PRESENT IN THAT
ROOM. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
MODERATOR NASA MODERATOR TO
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES TO A. B. SIX ONE SIX.
AND PLEASE LET US KNOW THE
NUMBER IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX ONE SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
TWO PARTIES IN THE QUEUE.
THANKS FOR PARTIES IN THE Q.
AND NINE THIRTY FIVE. I'M SORRY
NINE THIRTY FIVE IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BUT CANNELLA THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CRIME
GRAPE GROWERS- BECAUSE THE BILL
OVER THE NEXT YEAR BALLOT AND
CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CORRUPTION WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CONSIDER ENTER
WITH AGRICULTURAL COUNSELOR
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS PROBABLY A
LITTLE WITH CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M THIRTY EIGHT YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
GO ABOVE ME HAPPY AMERICAN
STATURE GROWERS CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL CALIFORNIA FRESH
FRUIT ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON HIM IN
WITH A CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MODERATOR- WE'RE
GONNA COME BACK NOW TO THE
COMMITTEE HAVING CONCLUDED ALL
TESTIMONY ON THE ITEM- ANYONE
ON THE COMMITTEE WISHES TO
SPEAK MEDAVOY SURE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK- I DO HAVE
SOME THOUGHTS ON A V. SIX- SIX
SIXTEEN THE IKE TO SHARE WITH
OUR MEMBERS. THE SENATE HAS
MADE OUR UTMOST PRIORITY THIS
YEAR TO PROTECT THE INTEGRITY
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS TO MAKE
DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES. AND
TO MITIGATE WHAT MAY BE
PERCEIVED AS COERCION
INTIMIDATION OR HARASSMENT
DURING VOTING PROCESSES AND
VACCINATIONS. I'VE BEEN PART OF
THAT. REMOVING THE ABILITY TO
BE ANONYMOUS FROM ANY VOTING
PROCESS WOULD ALLOW FOR UNDUE
INFLUENCE BY PARTIAL PARTIES
AND THEY WOULD COMPLETELY STRIP
EMPLOYEES OF THEIR RIGHT TO A
SAFE SPACE. TO EXERCISE THEIR
RIGHT TO VOTE OR NOT TO VOTE.
IT IS ALSO CRITICAL THAT WE
PROTECT EMPLOYEES RIGHTS TO
PRIVACY. I'M URGING MY
COLLEAGUES TODAY TO CONTINUE
WHAT WHICH WOULD WITH WHAT WE
HAVE DONE THUS FAR ENJOINING
CONTINUE TO UPHOLD HARD
WORKINGS CALIFORNIANS RIGHTS TO
PRIVACY SAFETY AND AN ELECTION
PROCESS THAT IS ROOTED IN
INTEGRITY. FOR THESE REASONS I
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CENTER LAYERED. HI
THANK YOU MATT MISTER CHAIR
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND I
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY. AND I
THINK THAT TO OUR- THE AUTHOR
WAS PROBABLY GOING TO ADDRESS
ALL THIS IN THE CLOTHES BUT IT
KEEPS COMING UP AND SO MAYBE WE
SHOULD GET RIGHT AT IT NOW
BECAUSE- I READ THIS SIMPLY AND
IN CONVERSATIONS UNDERSTOOD THE
SIMPLY. THE DISTRICTS IN
EXISTING PROCESS AND JUST
ALLOWED TO BE DONE REMOTELY AND
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT EVERYBODY'S
DRAWING CONCLUSIONS AND TO WHAT
THAT MEANS AND THAT SOMEHOW
THERE ISN'T A RIGHT TO PRIVACY
OR THERE ISN'T ARE CONFIDENT. I
WONDER IF YOU COULD JUST SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO IT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S THE HEART OF THE
TESTIMONY. THAT WE RECEIVED.
THIS SALUTE PLEASE HAVE HOW
MORE PRIVATE. AND PROTECTED CAN
IT BE IF YOU CAN TAKE A BALLOT
HOME. FILL IT OUT IN PRIVATE DO
IT YOUR WAY AND THEN DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT YOU'RE GOING TO
MAIL IT BACK AND NO ONE KNOWS
WHETHER NOT YOU MAIL IT BACK NO
ONE KNOWS WHAT YOU DO WITH THAT
BALLOT THAT IS THE ULTIMATE. IN
PRIVACY- OF FARMWORKER NOW CAN
GO TO THE POLLING PLACE. A LOT
ABOUT. IN THE EXISTING PROCESS
CAN TAKE IT WITH THEM. DECIDE
LATER WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE
GOING TO MAIL IT IN. THAT'S ALL
THIS BILL IS SO THIS SPECTER OF
BOOK OF LACK OF SECRECY LACK OF
A SECRET BALLOT. IS RHETORIC.
AND SIMPLY NOT TRUE. THERE'S
NOTHING MORE PROTECTIVE OF
SOMEONE'S RIGHTS. SECRET
BALLOTS PRIVACY AND TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE A BALLOT HOME.
PHILADELPHIA DECIDE WHETHER OR
NOT TO MAIL IT IN. AND AS YOU
KNOW IN THESE KINDS OF
ELECTIONS WHAT'S REQUIRED IS A
NUMBER OF YES VOTES ESSENTIALLY
JUST LIKE HERE. WE HAVE THIS
HABIT OF STAYING OFF OF A- BUT
IT'S STILL EARLY WE STILL NEED
TWENTY ONE VOTES HERE. FORTY
ONE IN THE ASSEMBLY TO PASS A
BILL IF YOU DON'T VOTE IT
DOESN'T CAP SAME THING HERE.
YOU DON'T MAIL IT IN. IT
DOESN'T COUNT. SO THE PRIVACY
THE SECRECY. IS PROTECTED I
WOULD ARGUE EVEN STRONGER IN
THIS CASE. BECAUSE THE
FARMWORKER DOESN'T HAVE TO GO
INTO POLLING PLACE. WHICH IS AT
A GROWER FACILITY. WHICH IS IT
IS IT OFFICIAL LOCATION THEY
CAN PICK UP THE BALLOT TAKE IT
HOME PUT IT IN AN ENVELOPE
PROVIDED BY. THE LABOR
SECRETARY AND GOES TO THE LABOR
SECRETARY WHO'S OBLIGATED. BY
THE- TAYLOR BE SORRY THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD IT WAS OBLIGATED TO
MAINTAIN THE PRIVACY IN THE
SECRECY OF THAT BALANCE. SO IT
IS A IN FACT A SECRET BALLOT.
IN A PROCESS THAT IS MEANT TO
FACILITATE THE ABILITY OF
FARMWORKERS TO MAKE DECISIONS
ON THEIR OWN OUTSIDE OF OUTSIDE
PRESSURES. VOTE AT A PLACE OF
THEIR CHOOSING. AND JUST MAIL
IT IN IT WORKS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHICH IS WHY WE
HAD WE CHECKED THIS WITH. THEN
SECRETARY OF STATE ALEX
BETWEEN. THE DOES THIS WORK. AS
A SAFE AND LEGAL VOTING
MECHANISM ANY SAID YES IT DOES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. WHEN
IT WAS INTRODUCED WHILE HE WAS
THE SECRETARY OF STATE SO STILL
SICK ABOUT. AND IT IS IN
IMPROVE PROCESS FOR FARMWORKERS
TO BE ABLE TO TRULY MAKE AN
ELECTION. THANK YOU. DECEMBER
CENTER WHERE DIGITAL FOR. YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE DANGERS IN THIS
BUSINESSES IF YOU ASK SOMEBODY
TO CHARACTERIZE THE MOTIVES ARE
STATEMENTS OF OTHERS AND HOW
THEY GOT THERE BUT I THINK YOU
WERE JUST VERY CLEAR. AND IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THAT'S AT THE
HEART OF THIS ARE. THE ONE I
FIRST AGREED CO AUTHOR OF THIS
IT SEEMS SIMPLE TO ME AND I'VE
BEEN SURPRISED BY THE PUSHBACK
AND I THINK YOU JUST SAID. UP
VERY CLEARLY AND I TAKE THAT AT
ITS WORD I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S- A MARK INCREASED
ABILITY FOR COERCION OR OTHER
THINGS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
APARTMENT. OKAY OTHER-
QUESTIONS DRAWS OF. OUR ARE I
JUST A COUPLE OF THINGS-
ARTICULATIONS ALWAYS GO FLYING
AROUND WHEN IT COMES TO.
SOMEBODY'S RIGHT TO VOTE WE SEE
IT HAPPENING ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY HERE- WHAT WILL
INCREASE THE ABILITY OF MORE.
PEOPLE TO VOTE AND FOR WILL
DECREASE THE ABILITY OF PEOPLE
TO GO VOTE. I JUST WANT TO ASK
YOU YOU COULD EXPLAIN WITH ALL
THESE ACCUSATIONS THAT SOMEHOW
THERE'S GOING TO BE- VIOLATIONS
OF YOU KNOW THE WORKERS RIGHTS
AND- COERCION. THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS- DOES ANY OF THE PROCESS
WITH REGARDS TO HOW YOU HANDLE
THOSE KINDS OF ACCUSATIONS DOES
THAT CHANGE AS A RESULT OF THIS
BILL OR MAYBE YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT. HI I
HAVE A HARD TIME ANSWERING FOR
SOMETHING I DON'T UNDERSTAND
AND I DON'T SEE IN THIS BILL.
CORES IN AS LONG BEEN A
CHALLENGE IN UNION ELECTIONS
AND THAT PRESSURE COMES FROM
BOTH SIDES. AND THE REASON THAT
WE SET UP THE VOTING PROCEDURES
WE HAVE IS TO ALLOW FARMWORKERS
TO MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS. AT
THE TIME OF THE ELECTION. ALL
WE'RE DOING HERE IS GIVING THEM
THE ABILITY TO FILL OUT THAT
BALLOT. AND MAIL IT IN ON THEIR
OWN TIME IN THEIR OWN WAY UNDER
THEIR OWN CONTROL. THAT'S
SUPPORT THIS BILL. WHAT I JUST
WANT TO ADD ON HAVING BEEN
THROUGH MANY MANY UNION- WITH
WORKPLACE ELECTIONS- THE IDEA
OF BEING ABLE TO VOTE IN THE
PRIVACY OF YOUR HOME- IS QUITE
EXTRAORDINARY AND I THINK
BEGINS TO BALANCE YOU TALK
ABOUT THE POWER OF COERCION
IT'S NOT A CO WORKERS THAT
COURT CHORUS ME- IT'S WHO HAS
THE POWER TO FIRE ME OR WHO HAS
THE POWER TO. TAKE OTHER
ACTIONS AGAINST ME THAT'S REAL
POWER OF COERCION- BUT- HAVE
YOU BEEN THROUGH MANY MANY
HUNDREDS OF WORKPLACE
ELECTIONS- BEING ABLE TO FILL
OUT YOUR BALLOT AT HOME- TAKE
YOUR TIME. NOBODY'S THERE OR IF
YOU WANT SOMEBODY TERE IF YOU
DON'T WANT WHATEVER YOU WANT
IT'S AND YOU ARE IN CONTROL OF
YOUR HOME. WHICH IS REALLY
DIFFERENT FROM HAVING TO WALK
INTO THE WORKPLACE. FOR THE
MANAGEMENT EMPLOYER ARE ALL
THERE- THAT THAT'S A VERY SCARY
SITUATION FOR MANY WORKERS SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SENATOR. THANK YOU SENATORS
WILL GO BACK TO PROVIDE SURE. I
DO SO FOR CLARIFICATION
PURPOSES- HOW WOULD YOU ADDRESS
THE CONCERN THAT. THAT THERE
COULD BE REPRESENTATIVES THAT
ARE ALLOWED TO FILL OUT THE
BALLOT AND DELIVER IT TO- TO A
WORKER. AND BE ABLE TO RETRIEVE
IT AND TAKE IT OR TURN IT BACK
IN IS NOT PART OF THIS IS THIS
BILL NO. INTEREST STILL
FARMWORKERS CAN GO TO A POLLING
PLACE WHICH IS AGAIN AT THE
PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT. AND THEY
CAN CAST A VOTE THEIR- CURRENT
PROCEDURE. WHERE THEY CAN TAKE
A BALLOT. THEY DON'T HAVE TO
TAKE A FILLED OUT BALLOT THEY
CAN FILL OUT THE BALLOT THEY
CAN TAKE IT HOME. WITH AN
ENVELOPE. THAT IS PROVIDED BY.
THE LABOR RELATIONS BOARD
WITHIN FISH LEVEL. THIS IS
STILL OVERSEEING BY THE BOARD.
THEY CAN TAKE IT HOME THEY CAN
FILL IT OUT IF THEY NEED
ASSISTANCE IN FILLING IT OUT.
BECAUSE THEIR LANGUAGE
CHALLENGES WHICH WE HAVE.
WITHIN FARMWORKERS COMMUNITIES
QUITE OFTEN. THEY CAN SEEK
ASSISTANCE. AND WE WANTED TO
KNOW WHO HAS ASSISTED THEM. SO
THERE COULD BE A PROBLEM WITH
ONE PERSON WHETHER IT'S
EMPLOYER OR OTHERS. ASSISTING A
LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH THAT WOULD
BECOME APPARENT HERE BUT THAT'S
FOR THE LABOR DETAILER BE TO
FIGURE OUT BECAUSE THE FORMER
CRITICS AT HOME FILLS. THEY MAY
GET SOME ASSISTANCEAGAIN
FILLING IT OUT FINE AS WE DO
I'M SURE WE ALL HELP OUR
FRIENDS AND FAMILY FILL OUT.
BALLOTS BECAUSE THEY CAN BE
COMPLICATED BUT THEY HAVE TO
SIGN IT AND THEY HAVE TO RETURN.
THEY MAIL IT BACK SO THEY'RE IN
CONTROL OF THAT BALANCE. I
DON'T HAVE TO MAIL IT BACK IF
THEY FEEL THAT THEY'RE BEING
PRESSURED. UNDULY BY ANY OF THE
PARTIES. THEY DON'T HAVE TO
MAIL IT BACK AND NO ONE WILL
EVER KNOW. HOW MORE SECRETS
THAT HOW MORE PRIVATE IS THAT
THE ONLY ONE WHO KNOWS THEN. IS
AYLER B. WHO COLLECTED TALLIES
IT HOLDS THEM SECRET. AS THEY
DO WITH ANY OTHER ELECTION. AND
THEN THE RESULTS WITH INTEL.
THANK YOU SIR THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL PROVIDES COMMERCENTRE
SORRY JUST OF. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STANDING Q. THANK YOU ANYBODY
ELSE. THE SOME MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS- I'M A PROUD TO BE ONE
OF THE PRINCIPAL COAUTHORS ON
THE BILL- THE PART OF THAT IN
THAT HASN'T CHANGED- THROUGHOUT
THE COURSE HERE IS THE- HAVING-
GROWN UP IN IN A FAMILY AND IN
THE BUSINESS OF. ORCHARD
FARMING AND BEING A GROWER- I
AM A VISUAL PERSON AND I HATE I
FEEL AS ANECDOTAL AS IT SOUNDS-
THAT THE ISSUE OF A BALLOT
ACCESS. IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT- FOR THE FOR THIS
DEMOGRAPHIC OF WORKER AND
ALWAYS HAS BEEN I THINK THE
INDICES OF. OF THAT STRUGGLE
THAT OF THAT CHALLENGE IN
INVALID ACCESS OR PER PRETTY
EVIDENT OVER THE YEARS SO WHILE
I RESPECT HIM DEEPLY YOU KNOW
THE CONCERNS OF GROWERS AND
OTHERS AND TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION BECAUSE- I SUPPOSE
FROM A BUSINESS STANDPOINT-
THEY THEY HAVE THEIR POINT OF
VIEW IN. AND AND WHILE I
RESPECT THAT- AGAIN I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON A
PROVIDING THESE WORKERS SOME
WITH THIS BILL OF THE KIND
ABOUT POLITICS IS ACCESS THAT
HOME. IT REALLY WE SHOULD
EXPECT PEOPLE TO HELP SO THANK
YOU- IT'LL. TURN TO YOU UP FOR
YOUR CLOTHES. I YOU MISTER
CHAIR EVERY YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF'S EXCELLENT ANALYSIS AND
WORK ON THAT BILL AND IF YOU
READ THE ANALYSIS IT'S VERY
CLEAR. WHAT THIS IS IT IS THAT
SIMPLE PROCEDURE AND- I ASK FOR
YOUR ABOUT. BROUGH TO WHOM DO
WE HAVE A MOTION. THE MOTION IS
BY CENTER DRAWS- IN LESSER
CONSULTANT TO CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR COURTESY
BY THE DISEASE. AYE CHAU BOGUE
NO. A SHOVEL NOW. RUSSELL HI
RUSSELL I LAYERED BY DAVID AYE
NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE. OKAY THE
VOTE RESERVE FOR HI ONE NO THE
BILL ITSELF THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR. THAT BRINGS US TO THE END
OF ORIGIN I WANNA THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THIS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US WHEN
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS AS YOU
HEARD MANY THESE BILLS
CONTINUE. TO MOVE THROUGH A
PROCESS- SO WE DO APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION SO WITH ALL OF OUR
CODE PROTOCOLS WE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT IS NOW AT CHERRY.
THANK YOU.